[Music]
a special shoe sale to help kids in need
local startup ross
and snow is holding a pop-up event this
evening while also accepting donations
for the
goody two-shoes foundation it's a great
organization over at the space is where
it's being held
that's right near polaris and harmon
sasha got the assignment of the day
she joins us now live with more of this
great event sasha
brian i already did buy a pair of shoes
our photographer has
evidence of that he took a photo we're
having a great time
out here at this pop-up event and as you
said a part of the proceeds actually go
to the goodie two shoes foundation which
is really the greatest part about this
you can see
lots of shoes to choose from here they
are here for another couple hours
through eight o'clock tonight
now rosten snow which was founded by
local husband and wife
fred and megan mossler is holding the
first ever pop-up sale this event here
and all these shoes are up to 90 percent
off they normally run anywhere from
three to four hundred dollars
the pair of shoes i got was ten dollars
so that really puts it into perspective
for you
now those here at the space say they've
seen people come in and out all day to
really take advantage of this
we've kind of seen people trickle in and
out all day this started at noon
and it's a really great way to get the
ross and snow name out there because
they're normally all online
and the best part as i mentioned before
they are encouraging anyone who shows up
today
to donate five dollars to the goody
two-shoes foundation that's the las
vegas-based non-profit
that provides shoe socks and essentials
to at-risk kids and they said
as well that a poor portion of those
proceeds
that from the sales will go to those
shoes as well
now before we go i have to say i have
found
a pair of shoes for you brian i think
they have your name written all over
them
their zebra print sasha
i'm on board so i can pick these up for
you right please do because sasha is
right
these are great i can't yes right by
them there's a jeff spicoli element to
that
from fast times at ridgemont high middle
agent above gets the reference
by him thanks sasha there you go
can't you see yourself just you know
walking into the studio with these
babies i think it's perfect
absolutely i'm doing it i don't know
their official name but they're now the
bryan loftis
yes all right well um if you want to
come down and get these brian
they're here until eight anyone else who
wants to snag these away from him first
again eight o'clock here at the space
near dean martin
and harmon we have more information on
our website ted you might have to fight
them yeah i think they're good
those are loftus loafers lofty loafers
they really are cool and the cool the
cool thing about these is they do all
have lining which is really neat
uh so yeah really great they have some
more subtle ones too these are just the
more fun ones